Bruce you can't keep doing this step out  of the shadows don't let tombstones be  your family legacy I know you're trying  to create a myth  just remember there is room for Bruce  and Batman inside that suit  this city has burned with corruption and  greed but Bruce's help a vote for Harvey  Dent is a vote to finally put your foot  down Vicki Vale reporter for the Gotham  Gazette is the dent campaign soliciting  votes from Gotham's biggest crime family  money gets money I can get Harvey the  mayor C or I can pull it out from under  your father despised men like Falcone  no one has ever managed to bring him  down  I haven't tried yet  come on  a fire is heading this way you must show  the world the true nature of a wade  sometimes I think this whole city's our  crime scene  a revolution is knocking on guffin store  when there's whole thing stars make sure  you're on the right side  well then time to save the city  you